KRISTIN: THE CORONAVIRUS IS
HAVING A HUGE IMPACT ON THE
ECONOMY FROM SMALL BUSINESSES
SIMPLY TRYING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
TO ANOTHER VOLATILE WEEK FOR THE
MARKET.
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IT ALL MEANS
FOR INVESTORS AND ALL OF YOU AT
HOME, WE HAVE TWC PARTNER MITCH
ROSCHELLE AND CAPITALIST PIG.COM
FOUNDER AND EDITOR OF A NEW TEXT
BOOK OF AMERICANISM WHICH I
BELIEVE IS ONE OF THE MANY BOOKS
ON THE SHELVES BEHIND US, FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JONATHAN
HOENIG.
JONATHAN, MITCH, GUYS, ANOTHER
TERRIBLE WEEK.
I JUST WANT TO RUN THROUGH SOME
DATA POINTS REAL QUICK.
WE’VE GOT CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
NUMBERS FALLING TO A 32-MONTH
LOW, UNEMPLOYMENT RATE JUMPS TO
4.5%, AND THOSE JOBS NUMBERS
EVEN WORSE THAN EXPECTED,
SURGING TO MORE THAN 6.6
MILLION, MORE THAN DOUBLE THAN
THE PREVIOUS WEEK.
MITCH, WHICH OF THOSE DATA
POINTS JUMPED OUT TO YOU AS JUST
THE WORST?
>> WORST TO BEST, KRISTIN.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE WEEKLY
JOBLESS CLAIM NUMBER BECAUSE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE THAT CAME OUT
YESTERDAY, THERE’S A LITTLE BIT
OF A LAG THERE.
THE SURVEY WAS DONE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE MONTH OF MARCH, SO
THE REAL INDICATOR THAT I THINK
THE MARKET’S LOOKING TO AND, IN
FACT, EVERY AMERICAN FEELS IT IS
THE JOBLESS CLAIM NUMBER.
AND THERE’S SOME ESTIMATES UP
THERE THAT ARE HELLACIOUS
SHOWING US WEEK AFTER WEEK WE
COULD GET TO SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, ANOTHER 5 MILLION, ANOTHER
10 IS MILLION COMING DOWN THE
PIKE.
THE REALITY IS THIS PROGRAM, THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM THAT
BECAME LIVE YESTERDAY, IS
INTENDED TO STEM THAT TIDE AND
GIVE SMALL BUSINESSES WHICH
EMPLOY 60 MILLION AMERICANS
MUCH-NEEDED RELIEF TO GET PEOPLE
BACK ON THE PAYROLL.
KRISTIN: SINCE YOU WROUGHT IT
UP, LET -- BROUGHT IT UP, LET ME
ASK YOU ONE MORE QUESTION ABOUT
THOSE PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAMS.
THERE WAS -- THIS IS A HUGE
PROGRAM, INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED.
IT’S BEING RUSHED TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THESE SMALL BUSINESSES.
BUT THE ROLLOUT DID HAVE ITS
COMPLICATIONS.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING ABOUT HOW
WELL IT’S BEEN EXECUTED SO FAR?
>> THE GOOD NEWS, I CAME WITH A
PROP.
THE FORM IS VERY SIMPLE.
THE RULES, LIKE ANYTHING IN THE
BANKING WORLD WHICH IS REGULATED
OR COMPLICATED, I THINK A LOT OF
SCRAMMING WENT ON LAST WEEK AND
BANKS WERE TRYING TO GET THIS,
THE RESOURCES PULLED TOGETHER IN
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ACCOMMODATE IT.
I THINK THIS WEEK, HOPEFULLY,
WILL BE A LOT MORE EFFICIENT FOR
BORROWERS.
BUT, EVERYBODY, THE WORD GOT
OUT, AND BORROWERS WERE
LITERALLY LINING UP AT BANKS TO
GET THEIR LOANS.
>> YEAH.
KRISTIN, I I CAN SAY EYEING
RONICALLY --
KRISTIN: YEAH, JUMP IN HERE,
JONATHAN.
>> WORRISOME THE FDA PROCESS,
LOOK, IT REMINDS ME A LITTLE BIT
OF THE T.A.R.P. PROGRAM BACK
DURING THE GLOBAL FINANCIAL
CRISIS A DECADE AGO.
YOU GOT TREMENDOUS T.A.R.P.
FRAUD AND ALL THE MALINVESTMENT
THAT PRODUCED, ULTIMATELY, THE
SLOWEST RECOVER IN MODERN
ECONOMIC TIMES.
THIS COMES BACK, TO MY MIND,
GETTING AMERICANS BACK TO WORK.
I MEAN, LOOK, YOU’RE RIGHT,
KRISTIN, THOSE STATISTICS ARE
STUNNING.
BUT WHEN YOU WARN WITH TEEN
PEOPLE, YOU FORCE THEM TO STAY
IN THEIR HOMES, WE’RE NOT
LOOKING AT A RECESSION, WE ARE
LOOKING AT A GREAT DEPRESSION.
WE NEED SOME WAY TO ALLOW
BUSINESSES TO BE CREATIVE.
YES, OF COURSE ISOLATE THE
VULNERABLE, BUT PERHAPS FOLLOW
MORE OF THE SWEDISH MODEL WHICH
IS NOT AN EXPLICIT LOCKDOWN AND
LET CREATIVE BUSINESSES FIND
SOME WAY TO PRODUCE EVEN DURING
THE PANDEMIC.
KRISTIN: SO, BUT JONATHAN, I
MEAN, WE’RE REALLY ONLY IN THE
GUNNING OF ALL OF THIS. --
BEGINNING OF ALL OF THIS.
HOW BAD DO YOU THINK IT COULD
GET IF WE STAY LOCKED DOWN
THROUGH THE END OF THIS SUMMER?
>> WELL, BOY, I MEAN, HOW, YOU
KNOW, HOW FURTHER DOWN -- CAN
THE THING I THINK THE PRESIDENT
DOESN’T UNDERSTAND, KRISTIN, IS
THAT THE ECONOMY ISN’T LIKE AN
ENGINE.
YOU CAN’T QUICKLY TURN IT OFF
AND ON, AND THE LONGER YOU ALLOW
BUSINESSES TO NOT BE CREATIVE
AND NOT TRY TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM, THE LONGER THIS SYSTEM
IS GOING TO PERSIST.
SO, YOU KNOW, AN EASY FIX, FOR
EXAMPLE, IF THEY WANT TO PUT
MONEY IN PEOPLE’S POCKETS WOULD
BE FOLLOWING THE HUBERT HUMPHREY
MODEL.
CUT SOME TAXES, CUT THE GAS TAX,
ALLOW PEOPLE TO PAY MUCH LESS AT
THE PUMP, FIND CREATIVE WAYS.
IF WE CONTINUE TO SHUT DOWN THE
ECONOMY, IT ISN’T JUST A
POSSIBILITY, IT’S A GUARANTEED.
KRISTIN: YEAH.
AND THIS REALLY TOUGH BALANCING
ACT THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
BEEN TRYING TO DEAL WITH,, YOU
KNOW, KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE,
HEALTHY INSIDE VERSUS KEEPING
OUR ECONOMY SAFE AND HEALTHY, A
REALLY TOUGH DECISION THAT HE’S
HAVING TO DEAL WITH.
AND THEN YOU HAVE, OF COURSE,
SOME FOLKS WHO SAY IT’S NOT A
CHOICE, IT DOESN’T HAVE TO BE A
BINARY CHOICE, BUT AT THE MOMENT